please to have on the show after I
believe for the very first time Rebecca
Lowe how are you Rebecca it's a pleasure
to be on indeed for the first time rich
thank you very much for having me I'm so
pleased to have you here I'm so pleased
for the reason why you're on here I'll
give you the floor on what this
announcement means Rebecca okay okay
well first of all just hearing you talk
about that just it just gets me so
excited just about an hour ago
we got official news you know what these
things are like if it gets a little more
than an hour ago but official news from
the Premier League the restart date as
you say Wednesday June the 17th for the
Premier League which is provisional
providing that all safety requirements
are in place at every club now there are
92 games left to play in the 2019 2020
season rich and what they're going to do
is pack them in big time but we think
that they're going to have them way more
often on your television than your use
so I mean we already over here in the
u.s. show every game but over in the UK
they're planning on showing every single
game across the for broadcast partners
BT BBC Sky and Amazon prior and that
never happened in the history of soccer
in the UK and the reason of course is
that fans are not allowed to go to the
game so the matches will be behind
closed doors and therefore in order for
people to see them every single game has
to be on television now normally just to
give you some context on average weekend
in the UK there are ten matches played
and five of them are on television the
other five all kick off three o'clock on
a Saturday afternoon and you can't see
the highlights of those until Saturday
night that's going to change for the
rest of this season starting June 17th
every single game will be available to
watch through the broadcast partners in
the UK and it is giving everyone an
absolutely massive lift at a time I
think we're desperation let's be honest
rich was starting to creep in we need
positivity we need lifting and we can be
both concerned and we can be both very
very clear with making sure few things
are in place but we can also be super
happy and super excited as you can hear
my voice I can hear you
what you just described Rebecca is is
huge and I just want to kind of bring it
into perspective for for my show's
audience and certainly you over there
Chris Brockman is because I was you know
by the way first of all you don't have
to say the words games and soccer please
you don't have to you don't have to
Americanize it that's number one
alright that's its no please you know so
but I was in a pub in London because I
was in town to call one of the American
football games and I remember I'm with
my friend dropping off some tickets for
him for that for that Buccaneers and and
Panthers game and I'm sitting there and
I'm watching people watch a television
show where people are just talking about
the Premier League yeah and I'm like
what do you I'm like what is this and
he's explaining to me that the action is
blacked out want and you can't see any
highlights until later on that night and
I'm like that's absurd that would not
fly with the NFL I can tell you that in
America so you're saying that now
they're just saying screw it we're just
going to start showing everything as
it's happening which has to be a
festival for fans of the Premier League
I mean they're saying screw it let's
just for the rest of this season but
actually a law and very certain it's a
law in the UK and the reason is rich but
if you show every game and the Premier
League you have to remember that the
below the Premier League rich there are
at least another four well there are
four professional leagues below the
Premier League it's a pyramid and then
another six below that and a semi-pro so
if you're starting to show every single
game then there's other leagues people
won't go to their local team who are
lower down the pyramid and watch the
games occur on the same time they'll
stay home watch Premier League so the
show that you're talking about it's
called soccer Saturday which is on Sky
one of our partners and nobody ever
thought that would work they were like
hang on a second our four guys watching
TV and we're gonna watch the four guys
watching that's never gonna work but my
goodness does it work it's one of the
most popular shows and it wouldn't work
the NFL because the horse has already
bolted you guys have you already show
all the game you already do that so you
guys at NFL and TV go hand in hand
soccer/football I should say started in
the 1880s in the UK so it happened way
before anybody ever oh you know yeah
it's gonna they gonna say screw it
they're going to do it for the rest of
this season but when next season starts
twenty twenty twenty-one probably
September it will revert well actually I
say that although I would have thought
that the fans won't be allowed in for
the rest of this calendar year so watch
this space perhaps this will continue
all the way up until they allow fans
back in which will be a huge amount of
games and a huge amount of show Rebecca
Lowe NBC Sports Premier League host here
in the Rich Eisen show and you're
talking about that pyramid and that's
kind of what I want to hit you with here
because there is no relegation in the
National Football League much to the
delight of I guess I'll say it Bengals
fans Jets fans right there's no such
thing as relegation but there is in the
Premier League how is that going to
affect like when when we're getting back
out there to compete you know Liverpool
is running away with it right now what
what is the competition going to be like
because I'm sure there are some some
football clubs that are not too thrilled
about getting out there and and having
the threat of relegation hangover them I
mean I think over the past few weeks
rich you've seen a little bit of
self-serving going off with quotes that
have come out of certain clubs sort of
saying oh maybe we should just you know
not avoid the season maybe that's just
the cleanest quick talking you're like
oh I wonder why they're saying that so
there has been an issue of that I do
think though overall the pressure has
been but that cannot happen and we have
to complete this season so everybody has
fallen into line and relegation will
continue to happen so you know coming
into the season three clubs will be
relegated and as long as the division
below has managed to restart three clubs
will be promoted from there just just
normal but at least they won't be
shouted out and screamed at by their own
fans in the stadium when they get
relegated only silver lining that is a
silver lining
okay so then just ballpark it for me
Rebecca do you think this is feasible
knowing what you know about how the
mechanics of of getting a club ready for
action
and getting out there and whatever
travel would be required and the
possibility that they're talking about
an FA Cup and then obviously Champions
League action should international
travel happen I mean how much of
expectation should our levels be raised
here do you think I'm positive I'm
positive I think it's feasible they're
gonna play in their own grounds I will
talk about having neutral venues but I
think they are gonna play in their own
ground in terms of travel Spain have
just lifted their travel ban and they're
about three weeks behind the UK so the
UK has some catching up to do
of course that I don't think the
Champions League will happen until
August anyway by which time I should've
thought the UK will have listed their
travel ban in terms of kind of how much
time the players need to get back to
fitness this is so unprecedented Brits
kind of these players are so used to
playing you know August round to May it
gets stopped in March they've all been
training at home but obviously only so
much you can do and now they've only
just started contact training yesterday
coaching each other on the training
ground yesterday so we're going to get
three weeks of essentially high-level
training before they play I would have
thought a lot of managers saying that's
not enough
some managers I just want to get going
but ultimately I think that the Premier
League wanted it to happen sooner and
the clubs wanted it to happen later so
they compromised with a three week
window and everyone's in the same boat
at the end of the day they just go to
their absolute best there is a worry
about injuries there is a worry and if
you look at the Bundesliga they've had
some muscle injuries in the first few
match week so there is that worry but at
some point rich we've got to get out
there we've got to try and get this
thing moving because we haven't got all
the time in the world there are people
relying on this for all sorts of reason
yeah of course no doubt and I know
watching some Bundesliga just no fans
and it's weird but it's something that's
got to happen as long as the action on
the pitch looks like the real deal and
is the real deal and the competition is
just as intense let's go right
absolutely I couldn't agree more and if
you look at the Bundesliga that is the
case I mean that the Savoy they play
football on the pitch and they're sort
of strangers we feel watching it
everyone is that the great thing about
human beings rich as we all adapt
whether you're watching it and you find
it jarring at the beginning a few weeks
in it'll be the new normal watching it
same with the players you know
they'll find it weird for a bit then it
will become normal that's the great
thing about the human race we know how
to at that and then fingers crossed in
the not-too-distant future everything
can go back to normal and then we will
readapt the you know readapt the other
way so I do I'm very positive about it
and I think that when people first see
that very first game and they remind
themselves of the beauty that is
football they won't care they just want
to watch the game so how fast Rebecca
will flopping just be called social
distancing how fast there are people
hoping I think this is a little
far-fetched but are people hoping that
those kind of things that you call
flopping we thought diving and the kind
of lacking of sportsmanship will go out
of the game based on the background to
what's going on in the world do we
really need to be seeing players diving
around and hitting their little tone and
crying and rolling around there are
people saying you know this is going to
change football players are not going to
do that no come on come on as long as
there is competition involving a human
being who acts as an arbiter whether you
call it a referee or her a referee or an
umpire there will always be another
human being attempting to elicit a call
that they do not deserve that doesn't
matter what's going on anyway who
doesn't love a good flop you are not
wrong Rebecca Lowe a pleasure having you
on and look forward to making this on
the regular as they were say thank you
have a great day cheers that's the
Rebecca Lowe hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here